hello everyone and welcome to not one
but two very exciting games by none
other than the reigning world classical
Champion ding L and it's been a while
since we've seen him in action and even
though this is not classical chess we
will have um his long awaited return to
the chess board in in a week or so in
the Tata steel chess tournament where uh
everyone will get a chance to face off
against the the reigning world champion
but here we're going to show a game
against two opponents first one against
Vanka will be in Rapid time format and
another one against uh
we that one will be in Blitz and this is
the semi-final game against Wanga in the
quarterfinals being defeated by jinshi
his old rival as um for those of you who
have been following chess for quite some
time now you remember in 2015 uh ding
created his Immortal game against
byinshi if you haven't seen it will be
the first link in the description below
it's been some six years since I've made
that video so should be a nice uh you
know trip trip down memory lane also you
can see me chilling in the background on
my couch and for those those of you who
are asking in the comments Meadow is
fine uh he just doesn't get up the
stairs that often now uh but yeah he's
still you know doing okay he's still
ancient he's like 17 now uh but doing
okay now let's check it out vanha uh
also if you remember in April of 2021
wanha announced his retirement from
professional chess and I don't think
we'll be seeing him in classical but he
did return for this China chess King
tournament at the face off against some
very strong opponents it's it took place
on the fifth and on the 6th of January
so no 6th and 7th so it finished
yesterday and yeah let's check out the
games and see how uh how ready is ding
for the for the Tata steel chess
tournament so one how with the white
pieces opens with Pawn to E4 we have
Pawn to E5 by ding Knight F3 Knight to
C6 and Bishop to C4 going for the
Italian game uh sorry about that uh we
have Knight to F6 uh and now PA Pawn to
D3 the main the main line the modern
Bishop's opening uh Bishop to C bishop
and E7 and Bishop to C5 are the top
moves here we have Bishop C5 castles
castles uh and now Pawn to C3 we have
Pawn to D6 and Rook E1 so everything
been seen many many times we often say
that Knight G4 isn't really an issue
here uh because you can simply play Rook
E2 defend the F2 Pawn kick away the
Knight win back your Tempo and The Rook
on E1 will The Rook on E2 will actually
uh be nicely placed later on you can d
up on E file with Rook a to E1 or
something uh But Here pawn to A5 again
very wellknown line Knight B to D2 and
Bishop to E6 and now uh Bishop to B5 and
Bishop captures are the main ideas here
but UHA goes for Pawn to H3 it's a
fairly rare move but it has been played
by some very strong players karakin
played it Duda played it Ki Krishna
played it vladislav ARF played it so uh
you know it's been it's been known to
happen Pawn to H6 and only now Bishop to
B5 returning to the to the main stuff
Queen to B8 going for the standard
approach Queen to A7 and then going
after the F2 pawn bishop captures on C6
B captures and now Pawn to D4 striking
in the center again all been seen before
Bishop to B6 and pawn to A4 later on if
you want you can shift The Rook into the
attack with something like Rook A3 Rook
to G3 Queen to A7 putting pressure on
the F2 pawn and now Knight to F1
preparing to REM maneuver the Knight to
G3 to support E4 while your queen and
Knight are doing a fine job of Defending
that D4 Pawn so Pawn to D5 and now just
Knight to G3 you could also maybe
consider E5 or E captures on D5 but
Knight to G3 is considered best D
captures Knight captures we have Knight
captures and Rook captures and the
position has been reached before Rook 8
to E8 is the move that was played but
here deing goes for Rook 8 to d8 and it
is now as of move sorry Rook 8 to d8 uh
was played but Rook 8 to E8 is what the
ding plays and it is now as of move 18
that we have a completely new game and
interestingly Rook 8 to d8 and Rook 8 to
E8 are the engine's top two moves so uh
for the moment we have a very very top
level game and okay W goes Rook A3 makes
sense that's why you played A4 uh Bishop
to D5 putting the bishop on this
diagonal you have the bishop and Queen
on this diagonal looks very nice also
offers a rook trade Rook to G4 Shifting
The Rook into the attack and now the
threat is Bishop captures on H6 which uh
you could very easily eliminate by
playing Pawn to F5 it it does look a bit
weird uh because for example something
like Pawn to F5 if Rook comes to G6 you
can go uh King to H7 and now you don't
have time for Bishop captures on H6 The
Rook is hanging and you go into all
sorts of um you know funny variations
like Knight A5 Bishop captures on D4
Queen to H5 it can it can happen but
black should be okay H but instead ding
goes for Rook to E4 he puts pressure on
The Rook so now of course you don't have
time for Bishop captures on H6 and he
puts put additional pressure on this D4
pawn and now look at what happened Rook
to G3 of course he still wants to play
Bishop captures on H6 and now ding
should just play King to H7 or King to
h8 just get the king out of that g file
but he plays Bishop captures on D4 he
grabs the pawn and this uh basically
loses in the game and I'm not showing
the clocks in this game they're not very
relevant but it is relevant that Vana
played all of his moves instantly so he
is really really well prepared for this
line uh he's actually at 14 minutes and
48 seconds and the they started at 15
minutes whereas ding is down to 9
minutes and 37 seconds on the clock and
now look at this Knight captures on D4
Queen captures Queen captures and now
Rook captures Bishop captures on H6
going after the pawn here King to H7 now
inviting Bishop captur on G7 but again
it is the strongest move uh Rook to D1
with check King H2 and Rook to E8 this
is ding's idea he wants to play Rook to
E1 and Checkmate the white King on the
H1 square but uh again how not wasting
any time he's playing uh this instantly
he he's playing so fast that he's
already above 15 minutes and ding is
down to six minutes on the clock so here
Rook to G5 uh and now Rook e to E1 now
okay one how made some room for the King
on G3 so Rook to H1 will not be
Checkmate uh Bishop to F6 and now King
to H6 ding moves in with the king so the
bishop cannot Retreat to C3 as The Rook
would hang uh and uh what can you play
here well you could consider or
something like Rook to G3 but then you
would run into Checkmate so although
it's a fine move not not in this
particular position so Rook G4 uh we
have King to H5 and now Rook to E3 uh
the cleanest way would be Rook to C3
followed by um some uh Rook to C2 ideas
but here uh vanha really had to um spend
some time to figure out how to get back
into this and now he's already down to 5
minutes and 40 seconds and the ding has
some four minutes on the clock uh Rook
to E3 is what he plays he wants to trade
down and get rid of any mating ideas
that the ding might have Rook captures F
captures and now Rook to D2 here ding's
only hope was Rook to E1 to stop Pawn to
E4 but he played Rook to D2 and now Pawn
to E4 we have Bishop to E6 and now comes
Rook to G5 with check and off goes the
A5 Pawn we have King to H6 and Rook
captures on A5 and now uh how do you how
do you play this well King to G6
attacking the bishop Bishop back to C3
and now Rook to E2 going after the pawn
and you might think okay let's just push
the pawn it's going to be defended there
but then you give up this diagonal to
the bishop and uh ding can easily draw
this and the first game ended in a draw
this is the second game so whoever wins
this uh goes into the finals uh Rook to
C5 just preparing to advance that past a
paon to Victory uh dink captures an E4
now PA to A5 and now Bishop to D5 if you
go uh Rook to A4 doesn't really do all
that much of the Pawn is defended you
can just gobble up all of the pawns and
you're I mean you're winning so instead
Bishop to D5 by ding now he wants to
organize some sort of an attack against
the white King Pawn to A6 we have Rook
to E2 and now of course you don't want
to allow Rook captures on G2 with check
King H1 and then all sorts of nasty
discoveries become possible so King to
G3 uh Rook captures on G2 with check
King to F4 now Rook E2 you have to stop
that pawn somehow Pawn to A7 Rook to E8
Rook to A5 and now Rook to A8 and while
okay you stopped the past Pawn but
Bishop D4 this Pawn is now here forever
and the white Rook is free to roam the
board Pawn to C5 was played but it
doesn't really do all that much how just
captures it and you cannot capture on A7
due to Rook captures on D5 so Pawn to C6
first and now even Rook captures on D5
just completely crushing ding C captures
and now of course I don't even have to
ask you what move wins the game as it's
the move that always wins the game and
that is Pawn to B4 this is what w played
and he was in this position on the Move
46 that the reigning classical world
champion ding Len resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
he loses the semi-final match and he did
go into tie breaks to fight for third
place um uh against uh his next opponent
their two rapid games ended in a draw
and then they went into Blitz Games uh
so we're going to show that one next but
here you resign because just B5 B6 B7
and that's it there's no counterplay
from black here whatever you play Just
B5 B 6 B7 it's completely relevant what
black plays unless black plays like
something like Bishop captures on A7
then of course you're going to take the
Rook but I'm guessing I don't have to
explain that so now let's uh shift our
attention to this no sorry uh that's the
Enigma uh let's shift our attention to
this game uh let me just switch the
letter on the little robot uh make it a
make it a Blitz game there we
go uh and uh here he is fighting for
third place uh against uh a very very
strong opponent we so let's check out
this game also with the black pieces the
other game ended in a draw whoever wins
this will win no uh uh wait I don't want
to trick you guys I don't think the game
ended in a draw let me just check out
the final tie
breaks yeah this is the first game ah
but none of the games ended in a draw
actually yeah we're just going to check
out this game first so uh we opens with
Pawn to E4 we have Pawn to C6 then goes
for the caroan defense and they will go
into the very very main line of the
caroan Knight C3 Capt uh captures on e4
Knight captures Knight to F6 and now uh
Knight captures on F6 e captures and
pawn to C3 uh the standard um setup
against this caroan bishop is coming to
D3 Queen is coming to C2 and black will
of course try to attack on the queen
side Bishop to D6 we have Bishop to D3
uh castles and queen to C2 we have uh
Rook to E8 with check and now Knight to
E2 and now Pawn to H5 we've had this
quite a lot of times uh even I played
this I think in two games in my rapid
sessions um as I always uh you know base
my base my movements on that famous game
dud that played against Magnus Carlson
where he defeated him uh Bishop to E3
Knight to D7 and now queenside castles
and in that game that of course everyone
knows B5 was attempted by Carlson and
Duda just crushed him with Pawn to D5 uh
the standard maneuver is Knight to f8
and then sh the Knight over to G6 if
needed but the Knight will be very good
on f8 so Knight to f8 King to B1 and now
Pawn to A5 the standard move here is
Bishop to E6 and there are many many
games with Bishop to E6 here then you
play Rook to C8 and you slowly develop
the attack but as this is a Blitz game
ding played Pawn to A5 first and now mha
counters it with Pawn to C4 now Bishop
to E6 doesn't look as appealing anymore
plus you cannot bring the queen to A5 uh
so here Pawn to a uh Pawn PA to A4 going
for Pawn to A3 and now Pawn to H3 Pawn
to A3 and B3 we have Bishop to D7 again
Bishop on E6 doesn't really do anything
so Bishop to D7 and now Knight to C3 and
now look at this beautiful setup that uh
uh way you created on the queen side
there's no good way to actually attack
this sure you could sacrifice a pawn
with B5 but it doesn't really do all
that much and that A3 Pawn is uh sort of
blocking your Rook so here we have
Bishop to B4 and now Pawn to G4 as the
situation on the queen side is you know
pretty pretty solid nothing really
happening in the center now Wei has time
to attack ding on the king side of
course ding will keep the G file close
he plays Pawn to H4 uh Rook H to G1 you
could also consider Knight to E4 if you
don't want to allow Bishop captures and
C3 and Bishop captures and C3 is
definitely a move ding should consider
since uh the bishop will not be doing
all that much here but the Knight might
become a very strong attacker Knight to
E6 we have Knight to E4 now and Knight
to G5 offering a trade of knights uh
which way he goes for we have Knight
captures F captures and Bishop to F5 we
have Rook to A5 now uh fighting for that
D5 Square also putting pressure on that
Bishop on F5 Now Pawn to C5 locking The
Rook out of the game and also the bishop
doesn't look all that impressive and now
ding plays Bish Pawn to B6 Bishop to E6
was again very nice but B6 was played
the idea is not to play Queen captures
because then D5 and the queen runs into
trouble but the idea is to shift the
Rook over to D5 and prevent D5 from ever
being played But Here pawn to D5 right
away Way ignores him and now uh how do
you how do you handle this position well
best would be to play C captures on D5
and then after C captures on B6 Rook to
B5 and the game continues however uh
here after D5 B Bishop captures and C5
was played and here ding is just lost he
runs into a terrible tactic he had 20 25
seconds on the clock we had some 38
seconds on the clock uh but the game is
now over and for a very uh specific
reason feel free to pause the video and
win the game for we while I give you a
couple of seconds you have a chance to
take down a world a reigning world
classical Champion
here so for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on realizing
that D captures on C6 has something to
do with it but it's not quite it because
Bishop captures on F5 also puts pressure
on the White Queen and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show is
Bishop to H7 check and Bishop cap since
Bishop captures on F5 is Black's only
defense against D captures on C6 uh
makes sense to move the bishop with
Tempo this is what ding missed King to
h8 was played now just D captures on C6
we have Bishop captures on E3 but it
doesn't really matter as C captures on
D7 comes with a terrible threat of just
Pawn captures Rook uh with a promote
motion to a queen so Rook to E6 was
played and here you could play a lot of
moves like f captures and uh here you
could bring the bishop back but uh way
ends the game on the spot he plays Queen
to C8 and he was in this position un
move 27 that dingler and resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here uh point is that uh if you capture
just another queen comes into the game
if you play Rook to A8 then Queen
captures a rook and A8 Queen captures d8
Queen and after all is said and done uh
you will be up a full Rook so of course
no point in playing that and other than
that you really have nothing here so not
the best showing by ding losing the
semi-final match to wanghao and then um
losing to way ye in the tie breaks for
third place so ding finishes fourth in
the China chess King tournament uh which
you know is weird it's the China chess
King tournament and it features world
champion ding Len but he finishes in
fourth place but okay this is Blitz and
Rapid we'll see what happens uh when he
uh takes on all all of the other
incredible play players at the Tata
steel let me just load this up I think I
have um the standings uh
somewhere uh really wanted to show you
that uh let me just check yeah I think
this is it yeah so this is the lineup
for the uh Tata steel chess tournament
that we will be covering uh in its
entirety uh so let's just check out uh
the
lineup okay there we go sorry about that
yeah there we go very nice uh so this is
the lineup of the Tata steel uh that
will start in a week uh so uh the leader
of course ding luren world champion at
2780 classical rating followed by Yan
pishi at 2769 ala fua 2759 Anish giri
2749 prand 2743 vidit 2742 we 2740 Paran
makulu 2740 abdat NRI 2727 GES 2725
yordan P Forest The Local Hero 2682
Alexander donchenko
2643 uh Max vardam also a local player
but you know he he always plays some
incredible chess 2625 and the Women's
World Champion ju Wun will be joining
them at
2549 also very very interested in how
she will do against this incredible
opposition the only player missing is of
course uh Magnus Carlson and he said
that he has um other plans and that he
will not be able to to join them and
this is the first time in like maybe 10
or 11 years that Magnus
uh well avoided playing the the Tata
steel so while that sad and everyone was
looking forward to magnus's clash in
classical against the reigning world
champion ding Len we will not be seeing
it um you know today or in a week when
it starts uh so yeah those were the
games hope you guys enjoyed it uh like I
said not the best showing by ding but he
did take a long pause and this is rapid
and Blitz I'm pretty sure we'll be
seeing a completely different ding In
classical uh but but you never know we
we'll see what happens uh so yeah those
were the games hope you guys enjoyed
that I would like to thank welshan
ditron wangan Sasha vidler and Mark
Henley Brennan for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day